you
ivorie one is jariyama and chest comms
tactics trainer and going to do another
group of three puzzles and simply share
my thoughts along the way
and I think I already have the answer to
this one this Queens unprotected and
there's a trick with bishop here check
and we pick up the Queen I must admit
that this is the first move I considered
seeing this battery Queen check and then
picking up the rook but we have better
with Bishop here okay I don't think I'm
missing anything that's a simple start
to this group of three alright so just a
little trick based on a unprotected
piece for starters team black and this
one hmm okay this is a sensitive square
g2 one attacker one defender so is b2
one attacker one defender also this is
an idea there's some trick maybe here
with a pin because this is also some pin
you know what it might be it might be it
might be simply Bishop takes e5 right
away I'm saying that because I'm seeing
a variation where you could end up with
two rooks on the second rank and they
will crash through and uh on g2 but
maybe there is something a bit more
convincing ah okay yes there is so
initially I'm looking I was looking at
some pin against the Queen but also
there's a fork involved I believe we can
start out with rook takes b4 yeah yeah
this is the trick
taking on before hitting the Queen
hitting the bishop on Queen takes rook
then Bishop takes c5 hits with the fork
and you pick up the Queen as it stands
right now the
well we're down a couple ponds mmm now
we're gonna be winning more than just
the Queen though rook takes Queen takes
Bishop takes c5 the Queen's I'm
protected so on Queen takes Bishop if
there's Queen takes Queen check and then
at the end we could scoop up the bishop
on b2 and so after the smoke clears
it'll be two rooks versus a queen and
rook yeah that's pretty much going to be
a after rook takes B if the Queen goes
somewhere I don't know just runs away to
d8 you grab the bishop yeah that should
pretty much be it yep
that's gonna do it it takes B for a fork
followed up with another fork grab the
Queen puzzle end yes okay that one
wasn't too bad I'm just to go back here
recognizing these sensitive points the
beat to be Foursquare yeah if I'm just
to recognize the sensitive points in
this puzzle immediately I was drawn here
one attacker when an offender one
attacker one defender even before I
could identify as an unprotected one
attacker one defender and there's a that
could kind of point you in the correct
direction
looking at these forceful moves removing
the defender of c5 and this is also what
we might identify as something that's
unprotected I know has pawn support but
just looking at it as two to two
defenders two attackers these are all
sensitive points C 5 B 4 B 2 G 2
okay let's try one last one these first
two were not too bad let's see what the
last one is going to give us here hmm
okay well my first thought is is there
some back ranked trick black does not
yet have a flight square I see our
knight is under fire hmm that's Bishop's
unprotected if we take the bishop rook
takes Bishop takes rook takes Knight and
we're not going anywhere we clip double
rooks and threatened a mate in two but
suppose black simply makes a flight
square now what let's see hmm
this is a bit tricky here and he capture
here at least on this first move doesn't
really do too much hmm
I mean on Bishop takes Bishop there's
rook takes here and then what hmm
our night is under
material-wise we are while it's balanced
huh what else to look at what where's my
i pointing what are the sensitive
squares i still see this as sensitive v7
it was like we need more maybe it is to
start off with this main thread rook a
to d1 you can't take the knight just yet
suppose g6
what would we do then if we could have
this same position with rook on a to d1
inserted as well as a flight square I'm
just going with g6 since it's a dark
square off of the light color squares
but you know rook a to d1 g6
how can we make use of the fact that our
rook is now in the D file we could give
a check black doesn't necessarily even
have to take the bishop is supporting in
the rook on b8 would it be some knight
move oh maybe it is yeah I think 98 so
still based on this back rank idea this
little test I don't know if it's correct
but this little test that I'm running
with Knight c8 I'm considering it
because I know that the bishop certainly
can't take because of rook da but on
night c8 rook takes then we take the
bishop which is a fork we're going to
win the exchange so Knight c8 rook takes
Bishop takes Bishop and then we'll grab
the exchange next so there's something
more to maybe consider or not really
because Knight c8 is threatening mate
and still threatening to grab the bishop
whether or not the rook takes the knight
yeah that must be it then
so this one's based on the back rank
this isn't this is too slow rook A to D
one most direct is to interfere with the
rooks defense of the back rank here that
is correct and grab the bishop and then
when the exchange next that is puzzle
solved mmm that was probably one of the
weaker group of weaker group of three
puzzles that I've gone through in this
playlist but I guess you'll have that
it's been a while actually since I came
across some endgame like puzzle on
tactics trainer but yeah anyhow
feel free to share how you did sometimes
you have a weaker a weaker group
sometimes harder as usual feel free to
leave any feedback how you did with
these three in the comments section
below and as always I hope you got
something on this video that's all for
now
take care